all right yeah man yeah you usually
start with a track or do you like I was
right in work for you um very usually
time me and the boys getting the studio
and I can just go off a simple drum loop
that I like yeah my process it start
from just a whole bunch of premeditated
does the process of me thinking about
the ideas and what I want to say mix
yeah you know and by the time I get into
the studio I have to find that exact
sound that triggered the emotion or the
idea that I thought about two months ago
would you have more than one of those
going on at the same time like might you
have six of those before you're going in
the studio or do you do it one at a time
no I want to talk don't want that so the
concept will come you'll sort of live
with it and let it grow in you yeah do
you bake notes definitely all the time I
have to make notes because a lot of my
inspiration comes from me people were
going outside of the country or going
around the corner to my own neighborhood
talking to a five-year-old little boy
and I have to remember these things you
know I have to write them down and then
five or three months later I have to
find that same emotion that I felt when
I was inspired by it so I had to dig all
the way deep and see what were the
things that triggered the idea is it
always coming back it comes back it
comes back it comes because I have kilo
words that make me realize the exact
motion what drew the inspiration you
yeah man definitely that makes the
process it's a working process I'm my
worst critic wish you tell me about that
a little bit you're critical of your you
just want to be really good yeah it's
really about me challenging myself I
think my excitement indoor music is me
feeling like I'm never stagnant we
feeling like
I didn't get comfortable in and you know
my own skin of what I think is good or
what someone else thinks is good you
know stepping outside of my comfort zone
and and mastering it you know and that
excites me when I feel like I've
accomplished that it just keeps the the
hunger for more going like I don't feel
I can ever stop do you ever consider so
when you think about the challenge to
yourself do you ever consider the
listener or who's going to like the
audience at all or is it more like just
self-expression I used to I used to
consider the listener but now I'm in a
space where if I'm not inspired I can't
really you know do the music you know I
can't feel it I think I put enough hours
and work to be able to pin 100 bar verse
on the spot at any given moment but for
me to actually feel an idea and concept
has to come from me and a lot of times I
have to block out a lot of different
needs and wants you know just for my own
selfish reasons but at the end of the
day it comes out where you know whether
you like it or not you know you're gonna
know it comes from a real place and it's
gonna feel I'm unapologetic I'm not
compromising and it's gonna feel me has
it ever been anything that you felt like
I don't want to say that on a record
like it feels like that's a great that's
a great question I always said to myself
if I set it on record
I never retract my statements because
it's myself expressions you can have
your opinions on it you can feel a
certain type of way but it's how I feel
and I can't contradict that yeah at all
you know and sometimes I do come across
them with them them lines you know us as
a rappers as you know we always have
that
another thing about it's where you know
it is controversy you know but it came
from some type of integration and I have
to say I have to be vocal about it you
know and you ever look back on
and feel like you'd like to change any
of the any of the things that you've
written or it'll be me saying I want to
go deeper I should have went deeper you
know I shouldn't have held back you know
but moving along I know okay you're not
going to be in the box of the sandwich
you want to say and that's where I'm at
now content wise do you feel like you
could talk about anything if you feel an
obligation to talk about certain things
I can talk about anything that's great
any I could talk about anything and this
is the challenge for me being able to
talk about anything and make it connect
you know to a listener with a listener
can either feel like you or feel like
they understand you or you have a just a
deeper connection to the music with
listen talking to a little kid and
making it represent something feel like
something or saying the most brutal
harsh things on record where you know
society may not want to hear no but
still having that connection and that's
why I think music is about for me period
do you think about how to ask this
let's talk about how you got to this
place of of doing this like what would
have been inspirations along the way for
you
musically lyrically or or
philosophically that got you to this
stage man as a journey think first off
had to be how I was raised you know and
environment we're having the the idea of
my father been you know just a complete
realist just in the streets and my
mother having this idea of being a
dreamer and me traveling the world and
doing all these things and I'm doing
today
it starts there first you know before I
even heard any type of melody or lyric
that wasn't planted in me first that's
just DNA you know who I am and the
things I talk about today is always the
end in the game the good versus the and
that's how I feel as a person eventually
that you know eventually that uh that
push me toward the music that I love to
listen to you know you came from Tupac
biggie Jay I mean you know your usual
suspect these were the people that was
played in my household that not only I
love to listen to but it kind of
complemented my DNA because these
artists always had different
perspectives on life in general and they
put that in their lyrics and they put
that in their music and that's a kid I
connected with it you know because I see
my older cousins going through the same
type of feelings and emotion that these
artists are going through and as I
started to write and dig into my own
thing and just progressed in that same
nature you know who's that music playing
in your house your choice of music was
that the music your parents were
listening to how did you get exposed to
it definitely my parents parents my
parents fairly young in the City of
Compton and you know they were I was
basically growing up with them so the
things that they play was more in you
know there was the hip crowd you know so
I was being exposed to all these ideas
you know from Big Daddy Kane to easy to
the Bay Area too short you 40 you know
back to Marvin Gaye and Isley Brothers
up this this field of music you know
just brought it you know my ideas to
come we never would have thought in a
million years you know that I'd be doing
it it's amazing well you know sorrow you
know my first my first ideas of how I
want to attack music today
when did jazz find its way into your
world that's crazy
yeah it's a trip because I was in the
studio one day my guy Terrace Martin and
he noticed something about the type of
sounds that I was picking in my whole
catalog for my mixtapes to my EPS to
just my process of making my debut down
to where I'm at now he notices type of
instruments I was picking he was like
man a lot of the courts that you pick
are jazz influence you're a jazz
musician by default you know the way
your cadence is rapping over certain
type of snares and drums this everything
that a person on the saxophone and on
the horn you know compete with how they
hear music and that's something that
just opened me up and then you just
start breaking down everything just the
science I've been going back to mounts
Herbie Hancock I'm listening to you
sport like man I like that sound what is
that you know that's a roll King oh so
that's what I've been liking all these
years yeah you've been liking this for
years this is this is this is in your
DNA this is why you picked Surrey
instrumentals you pick so when was that
moment in when you had that experience
in the studio where you realized that
you liked it went around was that uh
about three months until my second LP to
pimp a butterfly I was gonna say that
that after hearing the first album yeah
when the second album came it was
completely unexpected yeah and everybody
was expecting you together yeah
definitely oh and I knew I knew from the
jump that there was gonna be a challenge
you know and for my listeners here but
if I'm challenging myself in studio I
want to challenge you as well so I just
went for flesh with a man and we build
everything from scratch yeah so do you
feel like this will be this is kind of a
funny thing because I'm asking you to
project the future it's impossible but
do you feel like
butterflied you could what do you refer
to it as butterfly to pamper butterfly
okay please there's a few as a few
things maybe to pick how you'd like to
call it
let's say the second album do you feel
like that's more indicative of where
things will be in the future or is it is
it more like that's where you are then
or now and we should based on the
difference between the first album in
the second album should we continue to
expect it to change that's a great
question again may not possible to
answer but tell me your best thoughts my
best thought the past answer I can give
you that was me then not to say that it
wouldn't be a continuous or would not
you know it always has some type of DNA
in my music but me as a person just
knowing who I am
I grow I'm like a chameleon you know and
then that is a that's a gift and a curse
for me you know what were so a gift
because it never pertains me to put me
in a box and my ability to express it
and still make the connection walk
wherever I go that's my high points and
that's something that I pride myself on
you know it's always come from organic
place beautiful it sounds like the
connection you're talking about really
is your connection to it more than other
people's connection to it right right I
think the thing that's infectious about
it and the reason other people connect
is they feel your connection to an exact
you know it's not even necessarily that
like probably a lot of people who who
are your fans who heard your last record
might not have been that into jazz but
they feel your connection to it and it
inspires them to open their selves to
hear new music that they might not have
heard that is so true and a so true and
you can look at a person you have a
conversation with them and you know if
you know whether it's the music or who
they identify themself with
from an organic place a real place and
we called the consumers you know we've
been told Carla consumer is done but
then they're not they know when it's
real absolutely and they know if they
can fill it you know and that's
something I always understood you know
you're being a family so you know when I
looked at still today when I look at my
certain aspirations as far as artists
when I look at Eminem and I look at Jay
I felt you know this is the stories they
were telling you know whether it was
fiction or not these these these ideas
that they was putting down made me
believe you know any and everything that
I was saying because it just came from a
space of whether realize the point was
just their imagination being so strong
you know it's so heavy you know that you
just get bombarded into their ideas and
that's how it comes across with you
beautiful I feel like even if you don't
agree with what someone is saying but if
they're saying it and you know that they
believe it yeah you resonate with it on
some level you don't have to agree with
it to to respect it and then appreciate
it's just human expression really being
them allowing to show themselves it's a
beautiful thing whether you agree with
them or not exactly and I say that's a
great great point because I always I've
always been heavy on vocal tone and
you know where you manipulate your
voicing and things like that because
different tones when you just deal gives
off different expressions you know I may
wake up one morning and feel I feel like
the scenery right here or I may make
wake up one morning feeling like the
depths of hell you know and you may hear
that crunch and that emotion but that
emotion it translate through the music
to the person I was feeling that way you
know the day before or the you know when
I wake up the next one and I always been
a huge huge fan of that when I hear you
I don't always know it's you because you
seem to inhabit so many different
characters with your voice right that
it's not it's not always clear that it's
right exactly that comes from my
personality and DNA and it also comes
from being a complete huge fan of prints
my father was a heavy heavy still to
this day Prince fan that's all he was
playing and I just set back and just
like I could never tell when it was
Prince for me
you know he had a fuss settle you know
he had this baritone he just gave you so
many different emotions you know but I
seen the way my father was always
connecting with him and I studied it you
know you know alongside of lyricist
study R&B I've studied soul you know to
even pop you know and eventually all
these things you know gathered up to how
I connected and approach me and it's
really beautiful it's a great it's a
great journey Iran Fred Shannon how do
you go into the studio experience versus
the live experience the difference heads
yeah your your mental state go and see
those thick man that is a whole nother
as a whole nother beast for me and I
Drive people record because I approach
the stage my stage performers the same
way I approach the studio I have to
think about it handle
and know how my mannerisms are know how
I'm moving you know all that is is it
has to be dead-on from you know from the
hits and the licks on how we rearrange
the idea just to give the fans a new
experience it's a process the same way I
sit with mixes and a mastering it's the
same way I sit inside that rehearsal
room to make sure that everything is
hitting on cue beautiful and talking
about the musical process how involved
you in the big beyond the vocals and
lyrics how involved you in the music in
them in the making of it in the choosing
of it in all aspects man I don't sleep I
don't sleep in my team know they can't
sleep because I just you know not that I
don't trust them yeah yeah you know I
have on percent trust in my team but I
just have to be there for everything I
know sometimes I Drive myself crazy but
it just makes me feel like you know not
only pushing them but I'm pushing myself
I just have to be involved man is it as
a freaky nature sometime but I have to
be there from everything from snare to
the hi-hat till we got to gang up
there's two more DVS
we got to snatch this out and let this
part of the section breathe no man have
you ever written written to a track and
then afterwards decided to keep the song
but change the track has that ever
happened oh yeah all the time
definitely definitely or in the case of
building on the track and the pieces
that we build it on yeah it sounds
better than the actual bottom yeah and
just being able to know how to be a
minimalist in certain areas and pull
something back and letting a new thing
breathe opens it of war and as these are
that's trial and error though this
summer I could tell you two years ago
six years ago but uh it has been plenty
of time then
no it's really just about pushing myself
and pushing the musicians to not settle
in you know we can do we can put this
into space where it could be better
so do you usually have the musicians
playing all together or do you do parts
individually sometimes we play together
sometimes we do parts individually and
if they're playing all together would
you like conduct or say let's try it
like this
yeah definitely I have to be I would be
everywhere it would be just a bunch of
crazy sounds you know no no no no
arrangement you know and and when I say
musicians it's not all the time someone
can play instrument yeah you know a
person they can chop and break down a
crazy sample as a musician to me because
there's a lesser loss art you see
someone that can pull out the MPC you
know from out the dungeons out to crates
gonna be able to break down some crazy
drums along with a crazy bass player you
know these the people that like around
yeah have you ever written
have you ever written anything more
before hearing a track almost like it
was poetry like you know like yeah a few
times I've I've written full songs and I
had to find the actual instrumentation
to match it well you know and that's
fine
yeah that's fun because it gives me the
I don't me but it gives the the producer
the freedom to build around the lyrics
you know certain words that get tossed
out sound just might crack over top of
that they know the cables yeah sure it's
cool to have just a lot of different
ways of doing it like yeah more moves to
the basket it's got to be good exactly I
never know how a song is gonna turn I
may think I know you know but it may
come a whole new direction it may give
off a whole new entity of his own you
know from the approach to how I wrote it
to be going in the booth just
freestyling it it usually comes across
with no sign of how how do you know when
it's good how do you know it is good how
do you know what it's done you know I
think that's the question I think that's
the question of our artists and just
people who create it's just a feeling
man you can feel it just a feeling great
is this it's not rocket science
yes I'm sure you know it's just that
feeling it's just that feeling that
everyone gets you know or that feeling
that you just get along everybody may
not get it everybody may not get it till
it comes out and it be that thing and
then they say oh you know have there
been any any reactions to your music
that have surprised you either songs or
projects where people reacted either
better worse different oh surprise yeah
my mom my first album good kid maad city
this was me being fresh in the game and
I already knew what songs
well in my head I knew her songs are
gonna be big records you know radio
singing I'm playing a game new artist
and you know I have enough knowledge
she's going through meetings and going
to labels and trying to get signed in my
early twenties and things like I just
know how the game works
so I'm creating these records you know
for the radio and you know just what
people just ear candy for people to
enjoy so in my mind I'm thinking these
are gonna be the biggest records on the
album you know but turns out that a song
called mad city where I'm just wrapping
it for maybe 40 bars or 30 bars it's
probably the most song with the biggest
connection on their projects and that
that threw me for a loop but it also
gave me an insight clear enough to know
sometimes it's not about you know what
you think is gonna happen know what you
feel you know people connect to things
in strange ways you know and then at the
end of the day you have to go with that
feeling
absolutely okay now the question based
on that
and forgetting thinking of what you
thought was gonna work commercially how
did you feel about that song on the
album in the context of the others in
the context of the Alec just as a as a
for your taste
where was that song I'm on your meter I
loved it
oh mama was it one of your favorite was
one of my favorites but I didn't know
yeah it didn't fear the formula created
with your face yeah it was one of my
favorites sure you know I hope that is
giving you confidence oh yeah oh yeah
definitely nothing has to fit a formula
if you go with what feels good to you
exactly that's what works he's having a
conversation the studio of the night you
know you know of course there are
certain rhythms in and then tempos and
certain note changes in the music that
immediately know a piece of the air but
when something just feels good it can be
a tree branch falling off the ground and
somebody hitting that right key or that
right lyric on that tree branch and it
be the biggest thing in life because you
just can't stop sound and you can't stop
frequency I'll truly believing music is
just like that and it's simple you know
let's talk about alright for a second
yeah it is it has become a sort of our
generations protest song yeah yeah and
when you wrote it did you have that in
mind was it did you think of it as a
protest song or you know what I had that
record I was sitting on that record for
about six months the beat for real and
between my guy Sam Taylor and Pharrell
did you doing it when you gonna do it
when you gonna do it were you gonna do
it it was on me you know I knew was a
great record I just was trying to find
the spacing and to approach it what was
what's the approach you know I mean the
beat sounds fun but it's something else
inside of them courts that Pharrell put
down
that feels like it can be a more of a
statement rather than a certitude
you know so with the blessings of real
and sound actually am I go right when
I'm a rock on it it put the pressure on
me and put the pressure on me to
challenge myself and to actually deep
and focus on something that can be a
staple and hip-hop and eventually I came
across it eventually came across that
you found the right words and what I
want to talk about you know it was a lot
going on and still to this day a lot
going on and now I wanted to approach it
as a more uplifting but aggressive you
know not playing the victim but you know
still having that yeah we strong you
know and that was one record that
executed exactly how my approach was the
moment I put that pen to the parent so
you had to beat for like six months and
then yeah Jennsen have any words that I
don't have any words
I think PP new P knew that that record
was special people at the record special
salary that the record was special they
probably knew her before I even you know
had a clue you know so I'm glad that
they they put that pressure on me to
actually challenge myself because
sometimes that's a writer you know you
can you can have that writer's block in
and you know you like a sound or a type
of instrumental you want to approach in
the right way so sit on it I think also
sometimes like the maybe like the right
content wasn't where you were at the for
those six months you know what I mean
it's like the universe has a way of like
the timing of it is not really our
control you can't say well I got this
track I like so I'm gonna write to it
now it's like it comes when it's
supposed to come and it's relevant in
the world
and like it works the way it's supposed
to work definitely just have to be open
to open to it and ready for it when it
comes exactly exactly
I remember hitting pee on the text in
like man I got the lyrics yeah you know
and type of lyrics - he's like I said
did you have a Scott over it before or
nothing
yeah had a scat ad and it had that
phrasing different Cadence's you know
hook we're not yet Pete had to hook oh
cool yeah Pete hook yeah he had - all
right that's him on the hook just saying
that the alright phrase what does
alright represent was we all gonna be
alright that was it you know I'm glad
that sparked the idea because that song
coulda went a thousand other ways
absolutely
yep thousand other ways what do you what
do you listen to mostly would you say
now like now my list of music right now
is ranging just a whole bunch of oldies
that's cool it's kind of trippy same
usual Marvin Gaye eyes you brothers I
don't know man I just would you say more
R&B than hip hop it's more it's more
army what's more so yeah could you
imagine making an album in the future we
are not rapping you consider yourself
first and foremost a rapper yeah
definitely yeah yeah I think I got the
confidence would okay yeah I got the
confidence for it now I have the
experience and the time to approach it
[ __ ] you know mashed up the idea and
the time to approach the right way I
think I can put it on feel like it's
really interesting now in with what's
going on in hip hop you seem it's almost
like you were throwback to when lyrics
mattered because it feels like so much a
hip hop today is more about vibe and
swag and personality and less about
words and sometimes sounds like even the
emcee doesn't know what he said
yeah that's right so it's interesting to
hear the sort of clarity and depth that
you go lyrically the clarity I got my
clarity just studying him when I was a
kid always you know how I got in the
studio was just all off curiosity I had
a love for the music but it was
curiosity you know the day I heard
Marshall Mathers LP I was just how does
that work what is he doing how is he how
is he putting his words together like
that what is that what's the track under
it oh that's a double was I live I live
what is that she's going to do a scene
you know I do that how's he projecting
eyes his words cutting through the beat
like that what is he what is he doing
that I'm not doing now that I'm into it
yeah he's his time is impeccable
you know Jesus when he want to fall off
to beat is impeccable you know and these
are certain things that do experience in
a time that you know I had to learn
lucky that you got to learn it as young
as you were yeah gave you the ability to
grow so much yeah definitely definitely
13 or 14 years always in one one of your
lyrics you you mentioned meditation do
you do you have a meditation practice
yeah man I have I have to have to have
at least 30 minutes to myself if it's
not on a daily every other day to just
sit back close my eyes and I bezoar
what's going on you know the space that
I'm in when you in music and everybody
knows this the years are always cut in
half because we always have something to
do whether we're in a studio for four
months they go by now you got on a roll
for five months they go by next thing
you know five years no one but you're 29
years old you know and for me now I have
to find a way to understand
the space that I'm and how I'm feeling
at the moment because if I don't it's
going to zoom I know I can feel no and
I'm sure you know I'm talking about
it just goes you know and then you you
miss out on your moment because you're
so in the moment you didn't know the
moment was going on that makes sense
absolutely yeah and can also get lost I
know some artists get lost in touring
and they become less relatable like like
the stuff they have to write about
doesn't relate because I all they know
is being on stage and accolades and yeah
hotels and like stuff that's like
doesn't it doesn't their reality is so
different than everybody else's reality
that it's not so interesting especially
if that's all you talk about
definitely definitely is definitely a
different it's uh like to call it a
cartoon you know you can really get lost
in so fast it's scary out there it's so
scary man and I'll how'd you get the
idea to do the 30 minutes every day or
every other day well just knowing my
scheduling at how much I just think
about music you know someone brung it to
my attention so I think about you know
it's nothing wrong with it it consumes
me and consumed with my library you know
right is it I can't think about nothing
else you know and once I started
realizing that you know okay I know that
I have to give it some time and space
every now and then you know and that 30
minutes helps and 30 minutes I was
walking tolling zone out and not think
about my next lyric you know and I
it gives me a restart a jumpstart and
refreshing lets me know why I'm here
don't what I'm doing beautiful it
typically take a long time from the time
you have the concept until you get the
whole thing written maybe not produced
the way you want would at least written
I'm is varies I've I've written concepts
and four songs three verses each 24 bar
16 bars 4 songs within an hour or six
months it just itches it just it just
moves like that sometimes funny when you
have the concept you said before that
you surprised sometimes about how the
record comes out yeah but but do you do
you know the message you're trying to
get across before oh yeah so you always
know that in advance
definitely that's um those that nature
come from the skills of lovin to write
in school and knowing how to engage the
listener knowing where I'm gonna land it
or when I'm you know where it's gonna
end where it's not going to end you know
that's always been uh something I was
always unique about and really focused
on know what does this thing go you know
and I have that premeditated in the
process of pushing the lyrics earliest
memory of music being in living room and
watching we want easy how old would you
say you were had to be four maybe
actually said you before him busting out
it was a scene where he bust out of jail
on stage and he's rapping his verse
that's my earliest memories I think and
after that it would be Snoop Dogg's
nothing but a jeep the hang I was heavy
into music
this one the box was out there he had to
order
you know they constantly ordered so the
song was coming on back-to-back and I
just sit in front of the tube just watch
it back to back to back to that alone my
parents planted every night a party and
party every night literally you know
films or television shows that mean mean
a lot to you or you I am definitely all
those things play a part to start on my
imagination you know any particular ones
you remember I used to look on the tool
it could be from Dennis two minutes it
can be from I was I watching fresh
prints all these things constructed my
imagination of what was outside of the
actual house that I was living in or the
neighborhood I was in because I'm
looking at these figures these figures
almost I like you know imaginary you
know you're looking at Will Smith as The
Fresh Prince you know he's actually a
real person but as a kid you see him in
a TV screen so to you to me I should say
he's almost like a character in a sense
you know when I looked at Michael
Jackson still to this day Michael
Jackson is the biggest imaginary
character for me because I never got to
meet him I've always seen him on
television you know I've always seen him
doing magic on stage you know so I'm
looking at this guy as just a fig my
imagination and me wondering how did
they get you know beyond to that
television screen so all these things
play the part with me beyond my men
today from the music to what I'm
watching and just my perspective my
perspective was always that I'm not just
watching TV I'm trying to figure out how
does he do that you know just curiosity
who would the people with any people
that he saw growing up that you had that
feeling about the heat
get to me and how did what was that like
like uh yeah
another bugged out oh that's crazy dr.
Dre yeah Snoop Dogg Dre for sure tell me
about your relationship with dread oh
man this is a great thing man because I
I once looked at it as a she's me being
an ultimate fan I'm still a fan to this
day but to actually sit down and have
conversations beyond the music he wasn't
just a figment of my imagination I was
watching on TV screen you know it's
almost confirmation the people I watch
they just didn't get there out of pure
luck they actually worked hard and they
are human beings we're really motion is
real drive real consistency real hunger
you know it's way deeper than just a fan
out you know that always tricked me out
cuz I I told him about the story when I
seen him when I was eight nine years old
with two part on Rosecrans fast for
fifty years later I'm in a studio will
and I'm telling that story and even he
remembers him say Butte I just you
remember that ah like yeah I remember
that everybody was on the street yells
cross the street from a burger spot yeah
that's my bird yeah I was one of the
kids out there I was watching crazy
crazy to me yeah crazy to me it's an
interesting part of it is there's both
the amount of work that goes into doing
it and being able to keep doing it's not
you know sometimes when you're a kid you
see the person on the screen think oh I
want to have that life but you don't
understand what goes into that right
into it but then also even if you have
the work ethic there's still a
tremendous amount of luck involved you
feel the best in the world zactly not
everybody gets to find out it's like so
many elements have to go right the Crazy
Horse
it is really alive it's true now it is
so much so many talented artists out
there like
cause every day and then you just don't
plan out it can be from their own
personal experiences or issues or
management it's something that is an
undescribable nature you know it's
undescribable nature for sure on the on
the second album you have the I'll call
it the poem that happens over and over
again yeah I remember he was conflicted
yeah and deaf um when did that idea come
up to use that over and over again they
came into the process of me actually
recording the records I wanted a threat
conceptually just ties in in the songs
I've always been a fan of just movie
flicks and you know writers in general I
just love writers man sitting a
screening where people just come up with
the craziest wackiest ideas you know and
that was a that was a process that came
along while I was writing the record you
know and it worked out you know as a
little soak we appreciate it
yeah shame but it wasn't uh there was no
influence of like there was some old
album you heard that did something like
that nah that's great it must be if
anything it was a movie subconsciously
in the back of my mind it resonates and
feels unusual but it it pulls you
further into it and then also sometimes
when I'm listening to it and it comes up
I remember the first time I wasn't
saying tuna so it's like oh wait a
minute I think I I think it messed up
yeah yeah it's playing again you know
like I mean those are things I like yeah
absolutely no they're fun and they're
flashy pulls you out of the normal
experience of just sitting back and
listening it's like it makes you
question what's happening here and then
it forces you to pay attention and we're
in fortune to listen again it really
does give or fortune you just don't
listen it on it is whatever your yeah
yeah yeah you know your taste maybe at
the time but you're gonna go back to a
division how do you celebrate when
something good happens that is the
that's the question of my team asks me
every day
really
I own office the actual moment or me
getting back in and doing something new
or furthering that I think that's the
thrill for me I think I feel the same as
you
yeah is this a crazy feeling for me like
it's not I don't know if it's not the
actual celebration for me it's about not
doing it again but doing something fresh
and it's almost like the opportunity to
do something new can you think of a
disappointment that you've had um
finding the balance between family and
that is the the disappointment because
when you're doing this it comes a lot of
sacrifice you're gonna miss a lot of
birthdays you're gonna miss a lot of
moments those are my earlier
disappointed the idea of that nor knows
you know times were coming in and they
came in it's gonna be more of it and me
not learning to find the balance it
always was a a stress you know for me
because you have you have certain people
you care about and you love and
sometimes you may get lost in the music
so far you may forget how much you mean
you know to the people that you came up
with on your family your mother or your
father you know you can hear it and you
can hear you know even if it's not as
blunt or as vocal you can hear the sort
of disappointment you know for the most
part of the people around you supportive
before yeah yeah definitely definitely
definitely their support about everybody
has feelings you know that sometimes and
in the position that I'm in you know
they may not want to express those you
know real finish because it may it may
bring worry or they don't want to bring
a warrior
to my life you know so then finding that
balance at the time do that it can be a
somewhat of weary situation you know so
on a personal scale that'll be
disappointment for sure but do you have
anyone around you who tells you if who
tells you if something's not good yeah
like either if you do something that's
they perceive as out of line or for sure
then I'd be head over heels right now
you know if I didn't have a certain type
of grounded pretty family team that just
have my best interest not only as in
music but as a person everyone that's
around me everyone that's even around
this you know this area has been with me
since I was 15 years old you know and
these are the same people I I keep
around and hopefully eventually I know
we you know grow you know as people in
our I'll grow some people in different
natures but I will hope that you know
these same people will continue to grow
with me because I I can't stop yeah you
know I can't stop and musically you have
anyone who's like it's not good enough
or you like ridic yeah your team will do
it - my team would do it - yeah man yeah
I think me that's how I became the
biggest critic of myself because through
their criticism you learned yeah my skin
better is tough yeah top dog himself you
know a CEO a company when I was 16 an
adverse ain't good that's whack you know
you know your kid I whack you know you
your feelings get hurt
but after costly you know you grow tough
kid yeah and you get better you being
pushed gets in service to you he said
everything that isn't certain - you
definitely definitely because it taught
me that to know what to do what not to
do on record you know as far as lyricism
as far as my approach because I've had
the training
I have to the rat boot camps been in
there with my team and just going at it
sleeping on couches for hours I've had
the process for 10 years plus and in
doing that you know I just developed a
critiquing and a liking for what I know
what I'm capable of
do you have any uh any idea of the
direction that's going coming next as
far as writing goes um it soon I have
ideas though I have ideas not have I
have a certain approach but like I want
to see what it manifests to you know I
wanna I wanna I want to put all the
paint on the wall and see where that
goes you know maybe you can help me with
that
sure do you usually like for butterfly
did you record more songs than the ones
on the album I have so many uh floating
around 24 bar 16 bars hooks really
mainly hooks hooks and courses and
bridges and ideas you know verses here
and there songs here and there but
really kind concepts of hooks and
references that I had in mind for other
people to sing things like that where do
you find the most inspiration you said
early when we started talking about
traveling around the world talking to
people and can you give me an example
just like one picture something that
happened that man it's mainly kids man I
always say this kids bugged me out
because they have no fear and nothing
like nothing I sit there and I talk to
kids like my little niece you know she's
2 years old but she fears nothing and
she has no concept of reality as we know
it that always inspired me to write for
some reason man it don't necessarily
have to be whatever the actual child is
pertaining to but it it gives me a
moment talking to them gets me moment to
step back and look at the world for what
I know it
what this kids easy and he said kids are
much closer to God in that way like I
said yet indoctrinated into society so
they're closer to just pure essence
exactly exactly because deep down we're
all kids at heart and I know I am I'm
the biggest kid ever you know so I can
be able to relate and communicate them
communicate with them in a way that I
watch most adults can't you know I'll
sit there and hold a conversation you
know and go back to the studio man and
write the most bugged out song you know
just because it just gave me like I said
gives me a chance to sit back and allow
myself to look at the perspectives of
you know a different spectrum of having
responsibilities and not having any at
all it's fun talking to you yeah man I'm
ready that's a great great great
introduction anything else you want to
talk about check out the spaceman I'm
gonna create his own yeah this is this
is to go inside record your eye exactly
[Music]